San Diego doesn't know what's in that
box we
do how you doing how are you we're back
we're
bigger Diego
I'm bog the Giant
creat and I can't wait to get this bag
off my head if you want to see my face
let's hear
it welcome to
Comic greetings Mighty
sanago s the a
listen the former Governor had six
syllables for California I can say
sanoor tell them why we're here I am the
Ambassador from the planet adanac here
to um very favor make trade
negotiations perhaps offer a Knighthood
in exchange for a badge we don't seem to
have a badge he talk so
much
oh B don't scare
anyone oh you big TIY that's
nothing okay now I'm a little scared B
come
down check out the wire channel the
scene.com for the entire giant creature
series